When we think about dishonesty, we mostly think about the big stuff. I did not have sexual relations with that woman. We're thousands and thousands of people. We're cheering as that building was coming down. Thousands of people. I said it for longer than seven years. I have never doped. The answer is I did not send that tweet.
当我们想到不诚实时，我们通常会想到那些大事。我没有和那个女人发生性关系。我们有成千上万的人。当那栋大楼倒塌时，我们在欢呼。成千上万的人。我说了七年多了。我从来没有服用过兴奋剂。答案是我没有发那条推特。
My system was hacked. I was pranked. It was a fairly he goes hey I know a way that we can both make a little bit of money. You give me information. I'm gonna trade on it. I will split it three ways. This kind of dishonesty seems so blatant. So wrong. And you said yourself wow I could have never done this. Like this is a different kind of a person. That's not me. I can't possibly be like that person. This is Dan Ariely, researcher and author of the book,
我的系统被黑了。我被恶作剧了。这相当于是他走过来说，嘿，我知道一个我们俩都能赚点小钱的方法。你把信息给我。我要利用它进行交易。我分成三份。这种不诚实看起来如此公然。如此错误。你自己也说，哇，我绝对做不出这种事。这简直是另一个人。那不是我。我绝不可能是那种人。这就是丹·艾瑞里（Dan Ariely），他是研究员兼作家，
The Honest Truth About Disonesty, How We Lie To Everyone, Especially Our Cells. Dan says the truth about dishonesty might surprise you. What separates honest people from not honest people is not necessarily character, it's opportunity. We also talk about Dan's personal life and what a life-threatening injury taught him about deception and self-deception. It's kind of embarrassing. Do we have to talk about that? Can we talk about something else? Yes. Dan Ariali is a professor of psychology and behavioral economics at Duke University. He is the author of the book, The Honest Truth about Disonesty.
著有《诚实的好处：我们如何对所有人说谎，尤其是对自己》（The Honest Truth About Disonesty, How We Lie To Everyone, Especially Our Cells）。丹说，关于不诚实的真相可能会让你大吃一惊。区分诚实与不诚实的人的，不一定是品格，而是机会。我们还谈到了丹的个人生活，以及一次生死攸关的受伤如何让他懂得了欺骗与自我欺骗。这有点尴尬。我们一定要谈这个吗？我们能聊点别的吗？可以。丹·艾瑞里是杜克大学心理学和行为经济学教授。他是《诚实的真相》一书的作者。
Dan, welcome to Hidden Brain. My pleasure, so nice to be here. Dan, with many Americans thinking about their taxes right now, I want to start with a counterintuitive question. Why don't more people cheat on their taxes? Most of us know the IRS is overwhelmed and overstretched, so rationally, more people are to get away with cheating than actually do.
丹，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。不胜荣幸，很高兴来到这里。丹，眼下许多美国人都在考虑他们的税务问题，我想从一个违反直觉的问题开始。为什么没有更多的人在纳税上作弊？我们大多数人都知道国税局（IRS）不堪重负、人手不足，所以从理性上讲，逃税能侥幸逃脱的人应该比实际更多才对。
Well, first of all, just by saying it, maybe you've increased the proportion of people who cheat this year, so maybe you contribute to the issue. But the truth is that you're absolutely right. When we look at this honesty, we often look at the half-empty part of the glass and we look at all the things that people do badly, but the reality is that we are really quite wonderful. We don't have to go all the way to Texas. We can think about all kinds of other cases. So in the last few years, almost every time I go to a restaurant, I ask the waiter if there's a way to eat and
嗯，首先，你这么一说，也许今年作弊的人比例就增加了，所以也许你促成了这个问题。但事实是，你说得完全对。当我们看待不诚实时，我们往往看到的是半空的玻璃杯，看到人们做得不好的所有事情，但现实是，我们其实相当不错。我们不必一直追溯到德克萨斯州。我们可以想想其他各种情况。所以在过去几年里，几乎每次我去餐馆，我都会问服务员有没有办法吃完饭然后
escape without paying. And you know, sometimes I get strange look, sometimes they ask me for my credit cards, but they always give me good advice. They say things like wait for a big party to come, go to the bathroom, there's an alley, I mean, they have suggestions of how to escape without paying. And then I ask them how often does it happen? And they say very rarely.
逃单不付钱。你知道，有时我会得到奇怪的眼神，有时他们会向我要信用卡，但他们总是给我很好的建议。他们会说诸如“等一大群人来的时候”、“去洗手间”、“那边有一条小巷”之类的话，我的意思是，他们会给出如何逃单而不付钱的建议。然后我问他们这种情况多久发生一次。他们说非常罕见。
And in fact, they say sometimes people leave the restaurant without paying because, you know, we forget whether we pay or not pay we don't pay attention and people call back and pay over the phone. So there's a lot of goodness in us and in fact the surprising thing for a rational economist would be why don't people steal more right why why don't we take advantage. So we do have some internal moral conscience. We have internalized the values of society and we don't need anybody around us. We don't need prison sentences. We don't need to be afraid. We make our own judgment of what's right and wrong and we adhere to those decisions. Not perfectly, but to a
事实上，他们说有时人们离开餐厅时没有付钱，因为，你知道，我们忘记了自己到底付没付钱，我们没有注意到，然后人们会打电话回来通过电话付款。所以我们身上有很多善良，事实上，对于一个理性经济学家来说，令人惊讶的事情将是，为什么人们不偷更多东西，对吧？为什么，为什么我们不利用这一点？所以我们确实有一些内部的道德良知。我们已经将社会的价值观内化了，我们不需要身边有任何人。我们不需要监狱判决。我们不需要害怕。我们自己判断什么是对是错，并且我们坚持这些决定。虽然不是完美的，但在很大程度上
very large degree. One of the things that I find interesting about what you're saying is that in some ways people are often unthinkingly honest. In other words, they're not actually asking themselves what room do I have to be dishonest. They're actually honest just because it's a rule that they're following. And of course, much of your work has focused on the flip side of that, which is that people are also unthinkingly dishonest. It's not just people who are trying to be dishonest, but people who are making small lapses, small slips without really thinking about it very clearly. That's exactly right. And when we think about this honesty, we often think about kind of big cases of people who've done terrible things. And in the research on this honesty, we've done lots of lab experiments, but we've also interviewed 40 big cheaters. But what was so
达到了非常高的程度。关于你所说的话，我发现有趣的一点是，在某些方面，人们往往是不假思索地诚实。换句话说，他们实际上并没有问自己，我有多大空间可以不诚实。他们之所以诚实，实际上只是因为他们正在遵循一条规则。当然，你的许多工作都集中在那枚硬币的另一面，也就是人们也不假思索地不诚实。不仅仅是那些试图不诚实的人，还有那些犯下小疏忽、小差错而没有进行深入思考的人。完全正确。当我们想到不诚实时，我们经常会想到那些做了可怕事情的人的大型案例。在关于不诚实的研究中，我们做了大量的实验室实验，但我们也采访了40名重大作弊者。但令人感到
interesting about these discussions is without exception, all of them, when you talk to these people and you try to figure out how did they get to where they got, and you say to yourself, wow, I could have never done this. Like this is a different kind of a person. That's not me. I can't possibly be like that person. But when instead, you asked these people to tell you what was their first step. What was the first thing they did? You can say to yourself, I could have done that. I could have seen myself in that case. And I can give you one example. One of the guys we talked to, his name is Joe Pepp. And Joe was a cyclist. He loved cycling, he loved nothing else in the world, but cycling.
有趣的是，在这些讨论中，毫无例外地，所有人——当你与这些人交谈并试图弄清楚他们是如何走到今天这一步时，你会对自己说，哇，我绝对做不出这种事。这简直是另一个人。那不是我。我绝不可能是那种人。但是，当你反过来让这些人告诉你他们的第一步是什么。他们做的第一件事是什么？你可以对自己说，我本可以做到这一点。我能看到自己在那种情况下也会这样做。我可以给你举个例子。我们采访过的一个人，他叫乔·佩普（Joe Pepp）。乔是一名自行车手。他热爱骑自行车，世界上除了骑自行车他什么都不爱。
He was in the Olympic team, the American Olympic team, and then at some point he went back to school to finish his degree. After a few years went back to cycling, he goes on this race, but he feels that everybody else is slightly faster. And he's incredibly frustrated and he cries that night. And one of his friends says, here's a name for a doctor. He goes to see this doctor, white coat, and a status cope, and the doctor prescribes to him a EPO. EPO is a drug that people use for cancer that increases the production of red blood cells. Really good thing if you need energy, right? It means oxygen basically.
他曾是美国奥林匹克代表队队员，后来在某个时候他重返学校完成学业。几年后他又回到了自行车赛场，他参加了这场比赛，但他觉得其他所有人都稍微快一些。那天晚上他感到非常沮丧，并哭了。他的一个朋友说，这里有一个医生的名字。他去看这位医生，医生穿着白大褂，挂着听诊器，医生给他开了一种EPO。EPO是人们用于癌症的一种药物，能增加红细胞的产生。如果你需要能量，这真是个好东西，对吧？它基本上意味着氧气。
He goes to the pharmacy, he gives him the prescription, his insurance company pays for it, he pays the deductible, he takes it to his apartment, he gives himself the first injection, then the next day, the next injection and so on, eventually it's a habit. Then he moves to another team, he finds out that everybody else is doing it, they do it more publicly. Anyway things continue, then there's a shortage of EPO. But he has a friend that has connection in China, on a Chinese team, and he puts them in touch with a Chinese factory who produces EPO.
他去药房，把处方交给药剂师，他的保险公司为此付了钱，他支付了自付额，他把它带回公寓，给自己注射了第一针，然后第二天，第二针，以此类推，最终这成了一种习惯。然后他转到了另一个团队，他发现其他人也都在这样做，他们做得更公开。无论如何，事情还在继续，然后出现了EPO短缺。但他有一个朋友在中国有关系，在中国的一个团队里，朋友把他和一个生产EPO的中国工厂联系在了一起。
He imports EPO for himself. Then his friends find out about it and ask him to import for them as well, so import for them as well. Eventually, he's a drug dealer. Now if you just look at Joe Pepp and you say, could I ever become a drug dealer who imports EPO, you would say no. But when you look at the first step, you would ask yourself, where exactly would we stop?
他为自己进口EPO。然后他的朋友们发现了，也让他帮他们进口，所以也为他们进口。最后，他成了一个毒贩。现在，如果你只是看着乔·佩普，然后说，我有没有可能成为一个进口EPO的毒贩，你会说不会。但是当你审视第一步时，你会问自己，我们究竟会在哪里停下来？
Imagine yourself in his shoes. Like it's the first day, you just came back to cycling, you do just as well as you thought you could, everybody's faster. Don't you cry? Of course you do. A friend gives you an address for a physician. Don't you go? Of course you do. A friend gives you an address for a physician. Don't you go? Of course you do. The physician gives you a prescription. Don't you go to fill it? Of course you do.
把自己想象成他的角色。就像第一天，你刚回到自行车赛场，你的表现和你想象的一样好，但每个人都比你快。你难道不会哭吗？你当然会。一个朋友给了你一个医生的地址。你难道不去吗？你当然会。一个朋友给了你一个医生的地址。你难道不去吗？你当然会。医生给你开了一个处方。你难道不去抓药吗？你当然会。
You get the prescription, you have all these injections. Don't you try once? Of course you do. I mean, when exactly would we stop? And one of the frightening conclusions we have is that what separates honest people from not honest people is not necessarily character, it's opportunity. Right? And if we were all in Joe's shoes, maybe we would have all been like this, exactly like that. One of the things that caught my eye recently, Dan, is that you had a paper that actually explores this very idea from the point of view of science, and this study remarkably was actually looking at how the brain operates as people were making these little deceptions. Yeah, so the brain is really a mechanism for detecting surprising things, right?
你拿到了处方，你进行了所有这些注射。你难道不想试一次吗？你当然会。我的意思是，我们究竟会在什么时候停下来？我们得出的可怕结论之一是，区分诚实与不诚实的人的，不一定是品格，而是机会。对吧？如果我们都处于乔的处境中，也许我们所有人都会变成这样，完全像那样。丹，最近引起我注意的一件事情是，你有一篇论文实际上从科学的角度探讨了这同一个想法，而且这项研究非常引人注目地观察了人们在进行这些小欺骗时大脑是如何运作的。是的，所以大脑实际上是一个检测令人惊讶的事物的机制，对吧？
The brain is basically working on adaptation. You get to a certain level of light in the beginning, it's surprising, and then you get used to that environment. And this is true across lots of things that the brain does. It turns out that the brain also reacts very strongly to a first act of lying, but then as we keep on lying more and more, the brain kind of stops reacting to it.
大脑基本上是在适应性的基础上运作的。你在开始时达到了一定水平的光线，这令人惊讶，然后你习惯了那个环境。大脑所做的许多事情都是如此。事实证明，大脑对第一次说谎的反应也非常强烈，但随着我们不断地谎话连篇，大脑对它的反应就有点停止了。
So we start by being aware of this, maybe being at this honest act, and we at least are aware of it, maybe being at this honest act, and we at least aware of it, but over time it just goes into the background and we don't pay attention to it. Hmm. You've made the case in several books and articles that lying in deception is not usually about, you know, a rational cost-benefit equation where people are balancing the advantages of deception against the risk of getting caught,
所以我们开始时会意识到这一点，也许是在进行不诚实的行为，我们至少意识到了这一点，也许是在进行不诚实的行为，我们至少意识到了这一点，但随着时间的推移，它只是进入了背景，我们不再关注它了。嗯。你在几本书和文章中提出过这样的观点：谎言和欺骗通常不是关于理性的成本效益方程，即人们在权衡欺骗的好处与被抓的风险，
but about something that you call the fudge factor. What's the fudge factor? Yeah, so the cost-benefit analysis, by the way, is the kind of the standard framework in economics, right? You say to yourself, how likely might you get caught? What will happen to me?
而是关于你所谓的“模糊因子”（fudge factor）。什么是模糊因子？是的，顺便说一句，成本效益分析是经济学中的标准框架，对吧？你对自己说，被抓的可能性有多大？我会发生什么？
What can I get away with? How much can I steal? And you basically do a cost benefit analysis. We find that those things don't really matter. What we find that matters is this intricate balance between wanting to get a bit more selfishly, wanting a bit more right now. I wish I had a bit more money, I wish I had more prestige, whatever it is. And on the other hand, wanting to look at ourselves in the mirror and feel that we're good honest people.
我能侥幸逃脱什么？我能偷多少？你基本上是在做一个成本效益分析。我们发现这些事情其实并不重要。我们发现重要的是这种微妙的平衡：一方面想要更加自私一点，当下想要更多一点。我希望我能有更多的钱，我希望我有更高的威望，无论是什么；而另一方面，想要看着镜子里的自己，觉得自己是善良诚实的人。
We can cheat a little bit and still feel good about ourselves. So for example, if you're on a 65 mile an hour road, if you're at 68, you don't think you're speeding. So we have this ability to rationalize our actions and to basically say, yes, you know, under FBI interrogation, I would realize this is not the perfect truth, but it's okay. There's still a reason for it. I can still rationalize.
我们可以作弊一点点，但仍然对自己感觉良好。例如，如果你在限速65英里的路上，如果你开到68英里，你不会认为自己在超速。所以我们有这种能力来合理化我们的行为，并且基本上说，是的，你知道的，在联邦调查局（FBI）的审讯下，我会意识到这不是绝对的真相，但没关系。它仍然有理由。我仍然可以合理化。
I can still explain what it is, especially when we don't think about it too carefully. Let's talk a little bit about solutions. You think that one of the things that the IRS should ask taxpayers to do is to fill out a testimonial that says, I declare that everything I say here will be the truth, only the truth. Nothing but the truth, so help me, God. Why do you think personal testimonials might be useful when people are filling out their tax returns?
我仍然可以解释它是什么，尤其是当我们没有对它进行过多仔细思考的时候。让我们多谈谈解决方案。你认为国税局应该要求纳税人做的一件事是填写一份证词，上面写着：“我在此声明，我在这里所说的一切都将是真相，只有真相，全都是真相，上帝帮我。”为什么你认为个人证词在人们填写纳税申报表时可能会有用？
Yeah, so first of all, we have data. I'll tell you about it in a second. But think about our oral tradition. When people go to court, we have data, I'll tell you about it in a second, but think about our oral tradition. When people go to court, we swear in the beginning, right? And we swear in the beginning, not because we think we know already everything we've said, but we swear in the beginning because we understand, as a society, as an institution, that honesty is about the mindset. And you basically say, I swear, I'll say the truth, the whole truth and nothing, but the truth.
是的，首先，我们有数据。我一会儿就会告诉你。但想想我们的口头传统。当人们上法庭时——我们有数据，我一会儿会告诉你——但想想我们的口头传统。当人们上法庭时，我们在开始时宣誓，对吧？我们在开始时宣誓，并不是因为我们认为我们已经知道了我们所说的一切，而是因为我们作为社会、作为一个机构理解，诚实是关于心态的。你基本上是在说，我发誓，我要说实话，全部的实话，除了实话什么都不说。
And you put yourself into the state of being honest from now on. Now what happened that over the years, lawyers got into things. And instead of using the oral tradition, we sign at the end, right? Every document you sign at the end, not in the beginning. So all of a sudden, it's not about your mindset going in, it's about verification of the fact afterward. But you know what? When you get to the end, lying is over, it's done. Like imagine that you would test a fine court, and you wouldn't swear in the beginning, you would swear at the end.
你让自己从现在开始处于诚实的状态。现在发生的事情是，多年来，律师介入了事情。我们没有使用口头传统，而是在最后签字，对吧？你签的每一份文件都是在最后签字，而不是在开始时。所以突然之间，这不再是关于你进入时的心态，而是关于事后的事实验证。但你知道吗？当你到了最后，谎言已经结束了，一切都完成了。想象一下，如果你去一个优秀法庭作证，你不是在开始时宣誓，而是在最后宣誓，
What? You would say, oh, oh, sorry, sorry, let me go back to the third thing I said that we changed my opinion. So what happened is that the legal tradition has kind of taken something that we all intuit, quite basically, that honesty is about the mindset and change it to verification. So that was the initial intuition for this. And we've done quite a few experiments. In one of them, we did it with a big insurance company. This was an insurance company that sends people letters that asked me how many miles did you drive last year? And if you drove more, you pay higher premium, you drove less, you pay lower premium, and people of course
会怎样？你会说，哦，哦，对不起，对不起，让我回到我刚才说的改变我意见的第三件事。所以发生的事情是，法律传统把我们所有人都凭直觉明白的东西——也就是诚实是关于心态的——拿走并将其变成了验证。这就是最初的直觉。我们做了相当多的实验。其中一个实验我们是在一家大保险公司做的。这是一家会给人们发送信件的保险公司，信里问我你去年开了多少英里？如果你开得多，你付的保费就更高；如果你开得少，你付的保费就更低，而人们当然
have the incentive to declare that they drove less because then they would pay less. And they had the regular form, which you filled the numbers in, and you sign at the bottom of the form, and we created a new version of the form in which people sign in the beginning. And what we saw was that people drove more by 15% in the condition when they signed upfront. Wow. By the way, we've replicated it in all kinds of ways,
有动机去申报他们开得少，因为这样他们付的钱就少。他们有常规的表格，你在上面填上数字，并在表格底部签名，而我们创建了一个新版本的表格，人们在上面签名。我们看到的是，在预先签名的条件下，人们开车的里程多出了15%。哇。顺便说一句，我们在各种方式上都复制了这一点，
including with the procurement offices within the US government, including with taxes in a country in South America, and including with a traveler insurance in Northern Europe. In all of those cases, you get people to sign something, they get into kind of a different mental state. They remember honesty, we kind of guard ourselves against being dishonest and then people feel things in a more honest way. I'm not sure perfectly honest, but more honest way. And by the way, we started by looking at the glass half full part of it.
包括美国政府内部的采购办公室，包括南美某国的税收，还包括北欧的旅行保险。在所有这些情况下，你让人们签署一些东西，他们就会进入一种不同的精神状态。他们想到了诚实，我们防范自己变得不诚实，然后人们以更诚实的方式感受事物。我不敢说完全诚实，但确实更诚实。顺便说一句，我们从观察半满的玻璃杯那部分开始。
This is a tremendously glass glassful story because it says we have the desire to be honest. Something about the education process gets people to want to be honest. We just need to remind people that they want to be honest and then it works. When we come back, I'm going to ask Diane about the virtues of deception and self-deception. Our case study, Dan Arieli, stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vitaantham. When Dan Arieli was 17 years old, he was at a graduation ceremony. Flares were being sent up to celebrate, and one went off too close to him.
这是一个非常精彩的故事，因为它表明我们内心有保持诚实的渴望。教育过程中的某些东西促使人们想要诚实。我们只需要提醒人们他们想要诚实，然后它就会起作用。回来后，我要问问黛安关于欺骗和自我欺骗的美德。我们的案例研究对象是丹·艾瑞里，请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。丹·艾瑞里17岁时，正在参加一个毕业典礼。当时人们燃放信号弹庆祝，其中一颗离他太近了。
70% of his body was burned and he spent the next three years in a hospital. This story is hard to listen to, but Dan's injuries and the experiences he had with doctors and nurses reveal a lot about human behavior. And they changed the way Dan came to think about deception and self-deception. It turns out that severe burns that cover all of your body don't go away. I didn't know it at the time, but I'm more than 30 years later now, and my last surgery was last year. It's a gift that keeps on giving.
他全身70%的皮肤被烧伤，在接下来的三年里，他都在医院度过。这个故事听起来很艰难，但丹的伤势以及他与医生和护士的经历揭示了许多关于人类行为的真相。它们改变了丹对欺骗和自我欺骗的看法。事实证明，覆盖全身的严重烧伤是不会凭空消失的。当时我并不知道，但三十多年后的今天，我的最后一次手术是在去年。这是一份不断带来“惊喜”的礼物。
It's a very, very difficult injury, a lot of pain in the beginning, very hard to recover, and then it keeps on, I mean, the challenges are just ongoing. So you get to the hospital, you're spending many weeks in the hospital, you're obviously in great pain, various operations and procedures are being performed on you. The doctors share with you how badly off you were? No, so first of all, I was in a hospital for almost three years in total. In the beginning, of course, all burn patients above 30% are kind of a risk of losing their lives and nobody told me that. I actually don't think anybody really told me exactly what to expect. But no, I didn't know how long it will be, I didn't know how painful it will be, I didn't understand
这是一次非常非常艰难的受伤，一开始有剧烈的疼痛，恢复起来极其艰难，而且这种挑战还在继续，我的意思是，困难是源源不断的。所以你进了医院，在医院里度过了好几个星期，你显然承受着巨大的痛苦，要接受各种手术和治疗。医生们有没有跟你透露你的情况有多糟糕？没有，首先，我总共在医院待了将近三年。一开始，当然，所有烧伤面积超过30%的病人都面临生命危险，但没有人告诉我这一点。其实我真的觉得没有人确切地告诉我该期待什么。但我不知道要花多长时间，不知道会有多痛，我不明白
what burns are. Nobody actually gave me this, you know, really sad view of how the future will evolve from the perspective of the burns now As somebody who studies dishonesty and deception and who has made a very strong case against deception You found yourself paradoxically looking back in hindsight thinking that maybe the doctors did the right thing that maybe they did the right thing by deceiving you and maybe you helped in that deception with a certain amount of self-deception as well. Yeah, and like everybody who gets injured in a deep way, I also contemplated terminating my life. I didn't have much power to do it,
烧伤到底是什么。没有人真正给我这种，你知道的，关于未来如何从烧伤的角度演变的可悲看法。作为一个研究不诚实和欺骗的人，并且坚定地反对欺骗，你回首往事时，反而会产生一种矛盾的想法，觉得也许医生们做对了，也许他们对你进行欺骗是正确的，而且你可能也通过一定程度的自我欺骗参与了这种欺骗。是的，就像每个遭受严重伤害的人一样，我也曾考虑过结束自己的生命。我当时没有太多的能力去做这件事，
but I certainly thought about that. And I think that if I had at the time a more objective view of what the future would hold, I might have tried to do that. So that's kind of on a big philosophical kind of meaning of life kind of part, but it also shows up in smaller ways. So I remember one surgery.
但我确实考虑过。我想，如果当时我对未来有一个更客观的看法，我可能会尝试那么做。所以，这是从宏大的哲学和生命意义的角度来看的，但它也会以更小的方式表现出来。所以我记得有一次手术。
So this was a surgery to my right hand. And after the surgery, they couldn't put cast on my hand, of course, because it was the skin. You can't put cast on the skin. So instead, what they do is they put these metal nails through the bone to hold the fingers. So I had two nails coming from the side of my thumb and a nail coming in each finger throughout the whole finger.
那是对我右手的的手术。手术后，他们当然不能在我的手上打石膏，因为那是皮肤。你不能在皮肤上打石膏。所以相反，他们做的是把这些金属钉穿过骨头来固定手指。所以我的大拇指两侧各有两个钉子，每个手指都贯穿了一根钉子。
And you know, kind of basically lots of needles poking out. And by the way, at the end of them, they would put something so I wouldn't poke myself at night if I by mistake got my hand too close to my face. And the surgery was done. And six weeks later, they were going to take off these nails. And I asked the nurse, when are they going to schedule the operating room to take these out? And she said, oh, you know, don't worry about it. We're going to just take
你知道的，基本上就是有很多针头露出来。顺便说一句，在它们的末端，他们会放一些东西，这样如果我晚上不小心把手离脸太近，就不会扎到自己。手术做完了。六周后，他们要拆掉这些钉子。我问护士，什么时候安排手术室来取出来？她说，哦，你知道的，别担心。我们就在
it out in the in the department. And I said, don't you have to put me to sleep for this? And she said, no, no, no, it doesn't hurt at all. And it turns out it really hurt. Now, it wasn't probably as bad as putting the nails in, but it was, it at all. And it turns out it really hurt. Now, it wasn't probably as bad as putting the nails in, but it was painful and it took a while to take these, I don't know, 15 nails or so. But think about the three weeks that I would have had agony of being afraid. This way, I had the same pain,
病房里把它取出来。我说，你们不需要为此把我麻醉吗？她说，不，不，不，一点也不疼。事实证明，它确实很疼。现在，它可能没有把钉子钉进去那么糟糕，但它确实很疼，而且取这些钉子花了一段时间，我不知道，大概有15个钉子左右。但是想想那三周的痛苦，那种充满恐惧的折磨。这样的话，我承受了同样的痛苦，
but without the dread that came up with it. Now, do I justify lying? It's very tough, but do I recognize that it contributed to my well-being and that I would have had three weeks of, you know, I was terrified as it is. You know, when you're patient, your lack of control and fear is just incredible. You're just lying in bed and other people decide what to do with you, when to do with you. The helplessness is tremendous. And being, having the fear of people pulling these nails out of me, without anesthesia and being painful, probably would have been very, very difficult to take at the time, adding to that. So, I am grateful. I'm grateful. I still think it's a questionable decision, but I am grateful.
但没有随之而来的恐惧。现在，我是在为主张说谎辩护吗？这很难说，但我是否意识到它有助于我的福祉？如果当时我知道真相，我就会有三周的……其实当时我已经够害怕了。你知道的，当你是个病人时，那种缺乏控制感和恐惧感是难以置信的。你只是躺在床上，别人决定对你做什么，什么时候对你做什么。无助感是巨大的。而且，如果还要承受人们在没有麻醉的情况下把这些钉子从我体内拔出的恐惧，那种疼痛，当时可能很难承受，这会雪上加霜。所以，我很感激。我很感激。我仍然认为这是一个值得商榷的决定，但我很感激。
I believe that at another time, a nurse introduced you to another burn victim who had survived, and she meant for this to be encouraging, but in some ways it had the opposite effect on you. Yeah, this was maybe two or three months after my initial injury and at that point I could see and I could talk a little bit and so on. And they brought somebody who got injured and because I had no view of what my future would look like, I kind of imagined myself basically going back to regular life. I didn't understand everything that was happening. And when they brought this old patient to come, he was supposed to to symbol recovery. He was, I don't know, 15 years after his injury. He was supposed to symbolize
我相信在另一个时候，一位护士把你介绍给另一位幸存的烧伤受害者，她的本意是给你鼓励，但在某些方面却对你产生了相反的效果。是的，这大概是我刚受伤两三个月之后，那时候我已经能看能说一点了。他们带了一个也受过伤的人来，因为我对自己的未来会是什么样子没有任何概念，我当时想象自己基本上能回到正常的生活中。我并不理解正在发生的一切。当他们把这个老病人带来时，他本应象征着康复。他当时，我不知道，受伤已经15年了。他本应象征着
somebody who's made it. And he looked terrible with very severe burns. It was clear he didn't have functions of his hands. You know, everything I have now, right? So they were correct. But at that point, it was a shock to realize that this was the future that they were, like, optimistically I could hope for. I was hoping for a much more optimistic future than that.
一个挺过来的人。但他看起来很糟糕，烧伤非常严重。很明显，他的手已经失去功能了。你知道的，我现在所拥有的一切，对吧？所以他们是对的。但当时，意识到这就是他们所说的、我乐观地可以期盼的未来，是一个巨大的打击。我当时期待着一个远比这更乐观的未来。
My own optimism was much higher than that reality. Even though they brought that patient to show me how life could turn out well, for me it was just a shock to the system. I'm wondering whether this experience helped shape the way you think about self-deception. Self-deception. You know, self-deception has been widely criticized, and obviously it has many consequences, adverse consequences, when we lie to ourselves.
我自己的乐观情绪远高于那个现实。尽管他们带那个患者来是为了让我看看生活可以如何变好，但对我来说，这只是对系统的当头一棒。我想知道这段经历是否有助于塑造你对自我欺骗的看法。自我欺骗。你知道，自我欺骗一直受到广泛批评，显然当我们对自己撒谎时，它会产生许多不良后果。
But many people have also made the case that if we don't lie to ourselves ever, life becomes often unbearably difficult, and not just when you're suffering from serious burns, but in all kinds of different ways we need to deceive ourselves to get through our day. What do you make of that argument? Look, there's no question that there's some truth to that argument. The question is how much of it, which is true for all questions about this honesty. It's true that this honesty is corrosive and destructive and terrible for society and so on. It's also true that we don't want to eliminate it completely. And the real question is dosage and under what conditions. And I can tell you that sometimes I think about my experience in the hospital,
但许多人也提出这样的观点：如果我们从来不对自己撒谎，生活往往会变得难以忍受，不仅在你遭受严重烧伤时如此，在各种不同的情况下，我们都需要欺骗自己才能度过每一天。你对这个观点怎么看？看，毫无疑问，这个观点有一定的道理。问题在于程度有多少，这对于所有关于不诚实的问题都是一样的。诚然，不诚实具有腐蚀性、破坏性，对社会等等是可怕的。同样真实的是，我们并不想彻底消除它。真正的问题在于剂量以及在什么条件下。我可以告诉你，有时我会回想我在医院的经历，
not just with deception, but with pain and with Medication and with placebo and with lack of control and so on. It's got a magnifying a glass and all kinds of things in life and including in deception and I I don't think I could have taken the physicians telling me exactly the truth. And a couple of years ago, I was asked to help a young guy who was burned and a relative of his asked me to send this kid an optimistic note about his future. And it was a tremendous torture for me,
不仅仅是关于欺骗，还关于疼痛、药物、安慰剂以及失去控制等等。这就像一个放大镜，放大了生活中的方方面面，包括欺骗在内。我不认为我能承受医生们对我说出百分之百的真相。几年前，我被要求去帮助一个被烧伤的年轻小伙子，他的一个亲戚要求我给这个孩子发一条关于他未来的乐观便签。这对我来说简直是一种巨大的折磨，
because on one hand, I didn't think his future was going to be very optimistic. On the other hand, I didn't think it would be right to expose him to the full brutality of the many years that are going to be ahead of him. I debated for about two days while crying quite a lot about like what to tell him and what not to tell him and I've kind of brought myself back to what I wanted to know and not to know. And eventually I found some kind of compromise that I was okay with.
因为一方面，我不认为他的未来会非常乐观；另一方面，我觉得让他直面未来多年将要面对的残酷现实也是不对的。我纠结了两天左右，期间哭了很多次，考虑该对他说什么，不该对他说什么，我最终让自己回想起了我当初想知道什么、不想知道什么。最终我找到了一种我能接受的某种妥协。
But it was certainly not the brutal truth straight up. not the brutal truth straight up. I want to wrap up with a story that moves us forward by several years because I feel like this is a wonderful story that reveals so many different aspects about human nature, the nature of deception, the nature of self-deception, the complexity of human behavior. You were once at an airport confronting a very long line at check-in. Do you remember the story of what happened next? I remember, it's kind of embarrassing. Do we have to talk about that? Can we talk about something else? As your own research has shown then, thinking about the
但这绝不是赤裸裸的残酷真相。我想用一个把时间推进了几年的故事来做个结语，因为我觉得这是一个绝妙的故事，它揭示了人性的许多不同方面、欺骗的本质、自我欺骗的本质以及人类行为的复杂性。你曾经在机场面对过长长的安检队伍。你还记得接下来发生的事情的故事吗？我记得，这有点尴尬。我们必须聊这个吗？我们能聊点别的吗？正如你自己的研究所表明的那样，思考那些
stuff that's embarrassing can be very revealing. It is revealing. Yes. So, okay, we'll see where you go with this. You know, I have an injury, but I'm not that injured. Huge line, and I'm there with a friend, and I ask him to go and get me a wheelchair. And, you know, I have a hard time standing for a long time, but I don't need a wheelchair. And he got me a wheelchair, and we checked in very quickly, and we cheated. I mean, I, I, which he did, I cheated, got quickly in front of the line. But, but the second part of that story was that,
令人尴尬的事情会非常有启发性。确实很有启发性。是的。好吧，那我们就看看你想聊到哪里。你知道，我确实有伤，但也没有伤得那么严重。队伍很长，我和一个朋友在一起，我让他去给我弄辆轮椅。你知道的，我很难长时间站立，但我并不需要轮椅。他给我弄了一辆轮椅，我们很快就办好了登机手续，我们作弊了。我是说，我——其实是他做的，我作弊了，迅速插到了队伍前面。但是，这个故事的第二部分是，
so now I'm in this wheelchair, waiting for the, for the flight, and I try to go to the bathroom. And of course, I try to go to the bathroom and of course I try to go to the bathroom with a wheelchair and the bathroom is just not designed for anybody With a wheelchair and I get really upset I get really upset that the bathroom is not designed for people in wheelchair Then it became worse Because then it takes me with a wheelchair to the to the plane and it turns out I mean seat
现在我坐在轮椅上等待航班，我试着去上厕所。当然，我试着去上厕所，我试着坐着轮椅去上厕所，而那个厕所根本不是为坐轮椅的人设计的。我真的很沮丧，厕所没有为坐轮椅的人设计，这让我感到非常沮丧。然后事情变得更糟了，因为接下来他们用轮椅把我推到飞机上，结果证明我的座位是，
I don't know, 37D or something. And now how do I get to the seats? The wheelchair that they gave me was too wide for the seat, we couldn't go through it. So he now carries me on his back to seat 37D, which was fine, but this was a flight from New York to London. And now how do I get to the bathroom? So it's kind of clear to me that I need to stay in character. And I basically don't drink and I don't go to the bathroom.
我不知道，37D还是什么的。现在我怎么去座位呢？他们给我的轮椅对那个座位来说太宽了，我们过不去。所以他现在把我背在背上送到37D座位，这倒没什么，但这可是从纽约飞往伦敦的航班。现在我怎么去洗手间呢？所以很明显，我需要保持这个角色设定。我基本上不喝水也不去洗手间。
He carries me on his back as we land in London. And then I decide to go and complain to the people from Air India about how they're not treating people with disability. And you know what, I had in me the frustration of somebody who's actually on the wheelchair. I truly went into character. Maybe I should have been an actor. I truly went into character and I truly felt the humiliation of somebody who actually needs a wheelchair and the airline is just not doing the right thing. So, you know, this was like unbelievable ability to pretend I was something that I am not and very quickly
当我们降落在伦敦时，他把我背在背上。然后我决定去向印度航空的人投诉，抱怨他们是如何对待残疾人的。你知道吗，我当时真的怀揣着一个真正坐在轮椅上的人的愤怒。我完全进入了角色。也许我应该去当个演员。我完全进入了角色，真切地感受到了一个真正需要轮椅的人所受到的羞辱，而航空公司却没有做正确的事情。所以，你知道的，这是一种令人难以置信的能力：假装自己不是那种人，并且非常迅速地
get into the character and truly get upset and get upset over this. Now, just to say something in my own favor, in my own defense, if I may your honor, I know you're judging me now. And I think if I was not injured at all, it would have been tough for me to just make up something completely. But the fact that I kind of have some difficult standing,
进入角色，并为此真正感到沮丧和生气。现在，为了说句公道话，为了替自己辩护，如果法官大人允许的话——我知道你现在在审判我。我想如果我一点伤都没有，要让我凭空捏造出这一切会很难。但事实上我站立确实有些困难，
I have lots of burns on my legs, not that I deserve, I should need a wheelchair, but it was kind of an easier jump. And I think this is kind of the thing with the slippery slope that we see and this ability to justify our behavior in all kinds of creative ways. By the way, I should say one more thing.
我的腿上有大量的烧伤，虽然不至于让我必须需要轮椅，但这是一个比较容易跨过去的坎。我想这就是我们看到的滑坡效应，以及我们用各种富有创意的方式为自己的行为辩解的能力。顺便说一句，我还要说一件事。
We find that when we look at personality tests of who cheats more, we thought maybe people who take more risks, maybe risk-takers cheat more. No, maybe intelligent people, no creative people cheat more. And why do creative people cheat more? Because cheating is all about being able to tell a story about why what we want is actually okay. And sadly, I think I'm creative. Dan Ariali, I want to thank you for joining me on Hidden Brain today. It was a pleasure even though you made me relive some a little bit humiliating moments, but I thank you for it.
我们发现，当我们查看关于谁更容易作弊的性格测试时，我们曾以为可能是那些承担更多风险的人，也许冒险者作弊更多。不，也许是聪明的人，不，有创造力的人作弊更多。为什么有创造力的人作弊更多？因为作弊全在于能够编造一个故事，来解释为什么我们想要的东西其实是没问题的。可悲的是，我觉得自己很有创意。丹·艾瑞里，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。虽然你让我重温了一些稍微有点尴尬的时刻，但这是一次非常愉快的交谈，我为此向你表示感谢。
This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Penman and edited by Tara Boyer. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Path Shah, Laura Quarelle, Thomas Liu, Kat Schuchnacht and Lushikwaba. This week we're giving a shout out to two unsung heroes, our colleagues Patrick Cooper and Dan Newman. Dan and Patrick work on digital media at NPR. They have brought creativity, coding skills and patience to the Hidden Brain page at NPR.org. Thank you, Dan and Patrick, for all your hard work. For more Hidden Brain,
本期《隐藏的大脑》由玛吉·佩曼（Maggie Penman）制作，塔拉·博耶（Tara Boyer）剪辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、帕斯·沙阿（Path Shah）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）、卡特·舒赫纳赫特（Kat Schuchnacht）和卢希·夸巴（Lushikwaba）。本周我们要向两位无名英雄致敬，我们的同事帕特里克·库珀（Patrick Cooper）和丹·纽曼（Dan Newman）。丹和帕特里克在NPR负责数字媒体工作。他们为NPR.org上的《隐藏的大脑》页面带来了创造力、编程技能和耐心。谢谢你们，丹和帕特里克，感谢你们的辛勤工作。更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，
please follow us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. stories on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们，并在当地公共广播电台收听我的故事。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。